[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream 126 q and a
here we go
we got two questions from the discord
this week uh which were a tie the last
time they sent them in and since we have
not been doing q and as i'm just going
to read them both all right
one
i'm an independent researcher so this
the discord is you can access the
discord uh if you join either of our
patreons
i'm an independent researcher outside of
academia and i'm having an extremely
hard time finding studies for a topic
where most of the papers are critical
theory and social justice
i'm looking for medical insight not
opinions on society
how can non-academics weed through
thousands of studies and begin verifying
what is trustworthy
are you snickering over there
um
i don't know that academics have any of
a better time here but um
academics have access uh depending on
where you are to
a library that may not erect firewalls
as well to you know pay wells firewalls
pay walls to block you but it's not like
the research is even any better behind
the paywall yeah that's really the
question is
you know we're
being
washed over by a tsunami of
garbage
and
i don't know of a single discipline that
has escaped it even things were that
should be completely irrelevant like
math and and
cosmology are
suffering from it and so
anyway you know i don't know i don't
know when we're gonna
revolt on the basis that
we
have to have a functional system because
we are all dependent on it it is our
life support system we are on a
spaceship and the life support system
has been
um
over
uh has been hijacked by numbskulls and
yeah i mean i think um
back
10 15 years ago
when brett and i were very very well
aware
of
many of the ways in which higher ed was
broken and peer review was broken and
science was broken and you know and the
granting agencies that were dictating
what kind of science was done and what
kinds of results were reported was
broken and the private public
partnerships was inherently evidence of
brokenness and all of this
um but still still have managed to be
surprised by some of what has happened
of late
um still back back in those days when
part of what i understood my job to be
was
teaching students how to review the
literature how to review the scientific
literature how to access it how to
the cats are brawling on the floor
behind me here um
how to access the scientific literature
how to interpret it
how to indeed
do what you say you know these were
undergraduate students who had access to
a fairly low quality academic library
but i would encourage them to go up to
uw's librarian
and such but the question how can
non-academics or new academics or really
anyone weed through thousands of studies
and begin verifying what is trustworthy
that long preamble was by way of saying
um
even with what i understood to be the
problems with the system then
um
i'm not sure that the following advice
i think the following advice is getting
ever less relevant unfortunately
but one of the things that i would say
to students was
you
you learn how to skim
first and you try to figure out and it's
going to be very different
depending on the particular questions
you're interested in looking at in the
fields
try to find the one or two or you know
wouldn't it be wondrous if it were 10
people who are doing work in that field
uh that you think are doing really
excellent work you know how is it that
you're assessing that um that's to some
degree related question but also a whole
other other question
um
once you find such a person uh you look
at what papers they cite and you look at
um you know who who cites them
and you start tracing you start tracing
basically through references cited lists
as opposed to trying to do
start from scratch searches uh in you
know in web of science or google scholar
you know whatever your whatever your
access point is
and
uh it's not
perfect because it would be great for us
to be able to do completely novel from
scratch searches whenever we are trying
to figure out whenever we walk into some
new topic
but
you quickly find that
if you were interested in
questions across a wide number of
domains as we are as many people are
that you
that it's helpful to have a way in and
sometimes that way in is
i'm gonna feel completely out of my
depth for a while until i find the two
three four people who seem to be doing
reliably
high quality work and then i will use
them as my jumping off point for you
know looking at who they cite and and
such
that's harder and harder now because
even the questions are being curtailed
by
by the granting agencies even more than
they were be being 10 and 20 years ago
yeah i have very little to add because
it feels like
the system
is obviously so deeply into collapse and
effective
suicide
that it's a little bit like asking you
know
okay well the titanic is going down but
which decks are best
you know they're all not best yeah i
mean
another thing when you know back when we
were professors and i was asked to do
actual peer review uh for
some number of papers uh at some point
the requests sort of stopped um i think
because i almost almost always
unfortunately one of the main things
that i came back with was
where's the hypothesis i don't see any
evidence that this is
a
hypothetical deductive work in which
case it may be interesting but it's not
science it's an observation that
pretends to be science because it used
some fancy stats in the middle
and
the fact that so many of the papers that
i was sent for for peer review
had no obvious hypothesis was suggestive
of
you know a deep rot in scientific
publishing
so any paper that at least
any paper that doesn't have an obvious
hypothesis
is
one that you should have read with
suspicion from the beginning and if it
does if it leads with a hypothesis uh
read on and and see what you see
um so my my rule is every paper should
either
lead to a hypothesis or proceed from one
and
so you know it doesn't necessarily have
to start with a hypothesis but if it
doesn't it's observational and then
should
lead to one but the problem is
even those that seem to proceed from one
um
may not have
right of course rewards to
pretending that you predicted something
and then uh you know rearranging the
chronology in the paper
in other words if you if you do an
observational study and you don't have a
hypothesis and then you see some pattern
in your data and you pretend you
predicted it and then you say the paper
you know reveals this thing then you
violated the
um
you violated the underlying philosophy
of science and it doesn't mean anything
it's worse than a paper with no
relationship to hypothesis it's a
fiction
and we have no mechanism for knowing you
know other than knowing that the person
who did it or the people who did it have
integrity
which is an outsider you're unlikely to
be able to assess
it it's uh you know it is a rewarded
kind of anti-scientific behavior yeah
so the second question from the discord
server this week is do you two ever lurk
on discord
um i have never been on discord
i have been on discord i will say i find
discord
so off-putting in its structure
that the
uh the architecture is not intuitive
and so anyway to the extent that i have
thought i'll just go on discord and
figure it out the fact that it's not the
kind of environment that you can just
explore and understand
causes me not to invest even if i know
that people that i would be interested
in interacting with are there hopefully
in the near term
we will have a replacement for that
community which will not have those
defects and will not have the onerous
terms of service that people who are on
the discord fear might be wielded
against them yeah
so we love the fact that there is a
vibrant community a vibrant dark hairs
community
can you see what's going on over there
um
excuse me we love that there's a vibrant
uh community there and um
both of us have interest in
participating and as brett has alluded
to just now and as i have on on previous
live streams we are hoping to have
something that is at less risk of
censorship and um
has different origins uh
soon
soon i thought there was another discord
question here but i'm not finding it at
the moment so we
we
will
get there if we get there
all right first question from the q a
site this week
reading is effectively a form of learned
audio visual synesthesia
we see symbols that experience a sort of
mild hallucination conveying meaning and
experience
music too though an intrinsic emotional
auditory sort
dance is emotio kinesthetic
art generally and so on how should we
view synesthesia through the
evolutionary limbs do we miss an
opportunity to look to deliberately
construct and train more forms beyond
reading its language only in its infancy
is language only in its infancy
also totally separate question any plans
for a live traveling lecture series
let's save that one for afterwards
um
i love these questions about synesthesia
i would love for us to uh be able to
spend time
[Music]
thinking about this in more depth on air
at some point i don't know that this is
quite the moment
i will say that i explored it some in a
piece that i wrote called memories of a
mugging
with which which raised questions of
from an experience i actually had of
which senses come online and which
disappear at a moment of acute
physical
stress
and
it
prompted me to think a lot about
indeed what it is that we are perhaps
curtailing in ourselves and and how we
are limiting ourselves
by both the categories by which we
define the the senses and the boundaries
that we lay around them i feel like
as i think i say in that piece which i
don't actually know if it's even
available anywhere now i must i must
have made it available somewhere um
it
children seem to be synesthetes
right like children and and
to what degree is that informed by the
environment that we hand them you know
those those
those like blocks those like carpet
those interlocking carpet blocks that
have the letters in them that a lot of
modern kids end up having
if a is always yellow and b is always
blue and i'm making up those numbers but
perhaps you end up
you end up with children as they're
developing understanding that a language
even exists that a written language even
exists
assuming that if a is yellow on the
floor when you fall on it then a is
always yellow and and therefore you have
a sense of
of letters for instance coming in
particular colors
so that you know to some degree
synesthesia is likely to be
generalizing from early experience and
you know when you have some experience
of you know a visual sort that has come
along with a sound and you may over
generalize and assume that those are
those are linked in a way that they're
not
but in general i do think that
synesthetes
are
displaying as you suggest in this
question
a
more fluid and creative approach to the
boundaries that are often useful
and often real
but breaking down those boundaries can
sometimes
reveal other truths that may be hidden
by them
so first of all i think we know that
that thing is true about uh children's
toys and numbers that people who
experience mathematics uh with
particular uh color and shape reference
it turns out that their
this connection exists
i will say i think this all goes back to
the question of why we have
subjective experience in the first place
and this is not obvious because our
experience
or because our conscious minds spend so
much time
engaged in
uh subjective experience in fact that is
effectively what they are
it seems like the way you would go about
virtually anything and that's sort of a
failure to empathize with creatures that
have no reason
for a subjective experience so you know
we anthropomorphize them and to our
detriment
but
the point is
you live in a color by numbers
subjective experience realm right you're
basically stuff is categorized you know
wavelengths are categorized by some
subjective experience which we call blue
you know yellow red all of these things
and the point is you
your
schema
is not written in stone
and it narrows it becomes more and more
efficient over time in other words
so early on you may
use an inefficient scheme and then your
scheme gets better and better and
therefore less and less interesting and
less and less flexible and then of
course you can push those boundaries
with entheogens or something like that
but
but in effect what you're
the point is yes children are more
imaginative right and less reliable and
this is an extension of that principle
that uh
the schema that they use is more
variable and less useful and then as we
become adults it gets
more useful and less variable and in
some ways that's too bad but
but the whole thing is colored by
numbers in the first place and that's
that's the important thing to remember
is
um
you are an isolated
critter in a world that does not
make visual sense you make visual sense
of it and uh that is not a
straightforward process
so it's got tons of assumptions built
into it
i also i'm going to recommend a novel
that was published in 2006
by a man named jeffrey moore called the
memory artists which is about
hypermnesia and synesthesia and i
haven't reread it since then but when i
did read it in 2007 i found it
extraordinary and got me thinking a lot
about synesthesia then
before i ever had the mugging that
prompted my further thinking about it
with regard to neurology and such
now i have to find
the questions again here we go oh
any plans for a live traveling lecture
series
yeah
we we have thought about this and uh we
would have loved to have done a book
tour that was live in fact we were
talking to someone who was awesome about
doing it and then you know kobe kept
making it very very hard so
uh we don't have anything formally
planned but it is uh is definitely a
possibility
early this january when our school told
my unboxed boys to stay home because of
a coveted close contact while vast kids
could continue to attend i decided to
pull them out i've been homeschooling
since then what do you predict for the
fall
home study has been incredible but my
nine-year-old misses his friends
uh
right i think there's two questions in
terms of what to predict for the fall
there's what actually happens
with covid and i would expect
bad stuff to return
and then there's what the political
structure wishes to do with that it may
wish to ignore it in which case it might
be that
this disappears into the noise of other
winter illnesses
or it could be that it wishes to utilize
it in which case it could be
a more
tyranny and it's very hard to predict
because we don't know what it's trying
to accomplish and whether or not it's
decided to switch topics and use
something else as an excuse for tyranny
um
but
uh
i
i i have serious concerns about about
what takes place uh in the fall and uh i
would not
i would not count on the fact that the
worst is behind us it may be or it may
be that the topic switches and
you know
what we are normally driving each other
crazy over is
about something different but the effect
is the same
yeah with regard to the particular
benefits of school versus home school
i think especially given what
many of the things that we know to be
going on in many schools at this point
if you are the kind of person who can
write this question you are almost
certainly going to deliver a better
education to your to your uh
daughter son i don't remember
um
but uh exactly as you say it's the it's
the social part of it that's so valuable
that you can't replicate right children
children should have others
um you know it's also totally artificial
that we put them all in a room with only
their same age that's very artificial
but children should be with other
children and learning from them and not
just learning from their mother or their
father or
you know a few adults and so that that
is
the extraordinary benefit of school that
of course all that zoom schooling
pretended didn't exist um which was
ridiculous
uh and that is the
the very big loss
uh that um
the children being home schooled alone
rather than in say a community a small
community of of parents who are
homeschooling
i think that's probably the biggest
negative
uh and there aren't that many
yeah
i wonder i mean i think partially the
problem is that those of us
who
did not
those of us parents who did not buy the
party line
sufficient that we found ourselves at
odds with
their schools
are sufficiently outnumbered
that
the obvious thing doesn't happen i mean
i don't know why we're sending our kids
to school in the first place it's like
we send them to a place where they are
actively being miseducated
what exactly is our rationale for doing
this okay it's because they need the
social stuff but on the other hand
what is the social stuff well they are
learning to sit masked with other people
who don't call out obvious [ __ ]
and
you know at what point do you say well i
don't know which tragedy of history
we're living in but it's obviously one
of them and
one's first obligation in such a thing
is to protect their children
and protect them from what well i don't
know what all they need to be protected
from but i do know that that's part of
it and maybe they should be gathering
you know all of the all of the people
whose parents recognize that school is
now an actively negative
anti-educational
place that instills conformity and fear
all of those people should probably be
gathering their children and making some
effort at
uh formally educating them but largely
just giving them
normal social
inputs and
insulation from
mental garbage
right that would be cool so i don't
understand why there's not a widespread
outbreak of this i don't understand why
we're all on autopilot with respect to
um yes it's terrible that postmodernism
has taken over college but i'm still
sending my kid there like okay i
understand that we don't know what we're
supposed to do instead
but
again we are all of us including us are
actively sending our children to places
that we know are hurting them and i
i'm amazed that we
haven't opted for absolutely anything as
an alternative to that
right that's awesome we do have at least
a uh
at least a temporary alternative for for
one of our boys coming up yep yep and
maybe it's
maybe that or something like it becomes
the replacement for in that case college
yeah
next
question
hey are you aware of the younger driest
impact theory and if so do you have
thoughts on how this would affect our
social evolution if there were advanced
civilizations before then
do you know of randall carlson's work
i don't know the name randall carlson
i do know ish about the younger dryas
impact theory and um
and thought that and did a just super
like 30 second um google scholar search
on
um
most of the paleoanthropologists and and
other people who think about such things
find
um
the evidence non-existent
for for this this is like so the idea is
something i don't remember uh like 10 to
13 000 years ago or something um it was
proposed back in the mid-aughts that
there was an uh an impact
extraterrestrial impact that wiped a
bunch of stuff out including evidence of
previous advanced civilizations i think
i may be combining two aspects of this
um but you know later analysis is like
yeah all the evidence presented is
either misunderstood or maybe even
fabricated in some cases and um really
doesn't add up to a hypothesis that
makes much sense that is my very very
scant understanding yeah i know even
less about it i think it seems pretty
unlikely yeah you know things like a sea
level change can swamp
civilizations that were
uh that were existing and you had one
fell swoop you can
uh erase an awful lot of stuff but
hard to imagine that that such a thing
was in play here yeah on that time scale
yeah yeah i mean that that's it you know
as as as dawkins has famously said
failure of imagination is not an
argument but there would there would be
evidence across so many domains that we
don't seem to have yeah that is uh that
is basically the the likely answer there
next question
our shrew-like ancestor most likely had
claws fit for climbing trees and we have
fingernails
is there a cool story to go with that
transition where might fingernails be
headed
um so i mean that we do we do have it's
it's not at primates it's actually at
the at simeons and so simians being
monkeys and apes um the the
so-called pro-symbians symbians that's
not a thing
so-called pro-simulance which isn't
really a word that's used anymore but
like the lemurs and the tarsiers and the
galagos and lorises
um
have um have nails still have have
rather have claws
and it's actually a
simian
synapomorphia a shared derived
characteristic of both the new and the
old world monkeys
that we end up with these flattened
nails
that
are
less good at you know claws help you
stick to trees as you're climbing
and nails
uh provide better access to the pads and
therefore probably greater dexterity now
all primates including those the
so-called proseminiums the lemurs and
lorises and everything have the
opposable thumbs and and big toes uh but
those would have been less useful with
claws and so the nails are uh almost
certainly at least
at least they help with and they may
well have evolved for
uh greater dexterity in grabbing and
manipulating objects with those
opposable thumbs and big toes that
already predated the nails
i've always wondered and have never
looked into it whether or not there's
anything about the idea that the nails
are
uh on the back side of these pads which
are innervated and of course innervated
meaning neurological like sensory
nervous system
uh highly sensory uh
um
i'm gonna struggle for half an hour
finding a synonym for innervated but um
but anyway the point is
maybe
the idea is if you need feedback
neurological feedback from the things on
your fingertips that actually a
a black at black a blank even
a slate effectively um might be the
perfect background for it yeah no i
don't know i don't know if that's true
and there's obviously bone between the
the pad of the finger and the fingernail
so yeah but but just a but just a rod of
bone it doesn't extend you know it's not
flattened it's not it's not directly
flattened i don't think yeah um
and you know that what are the nails
doing for us
you know i guess i mean they protect the
top of the fingers but you know they you
know the keratinized tips as i call it
when i clip off the keratinized tips of
our of our carnivore and friends so that
they don't wake us in the night by
scratching at us um
those pre-exist and so they're already
there and so it you know it may be that
there's not that much
benefit in having the nails but it's
better to have nails than claws and
maybe they start to disappear
right and in fact you can see that very
pattern in pinnipeds
so pinnipeds which are bears that have
become seals
um
you're going to get like half a second
of hate mail before right before
right
pinnipeds are what now pinnipeds are
bears that have become seals and sea
lions and if you look at their flippers
what you actually see is that their
nails have moved back
onto the middle of the flipper
right is that right yeah i've never
gotten that close to a penny it's pretty
pretty wild actually um so they're still
there they've just receded and so i'm
sort of questioning the fleshy part is
is all you see at the very tip yeah yeah
so if you yeah actually that's
and they still have all of them i'm
trying to remember there's a difference
between seals and sea lions in this
regard and i'm trying to remember
exactly what it is but one of them has
ears um you could actually you i don't
know if you can do with that external
pin is one of them right
um but anyway anyway the point is maybe
the
importance of
seals versus sea lions in terms of the
nails
now we'll see if that brings anything up
if you just said let's say
seal and sea lion
claws
you get images but
um yes
front feet
um
noisy earless
can you just google sea lion flipper and
seal flipper and then look at the images
but anyway my argument was going to be
maybe
the
[Music]
evolution has built a reluctance to lose
claws
because any ancestor that had lost claws
would have a huge disadvantage and so at
the point that bears become aquatic and
they are seals and sea lions
that
they
these would be moved out of the way now
of course i also do think that there's a
certain amount of scratching that they
actually still do with them they're not
they totally do yeah
uh so i don't
the seal they kind of
at least at the moment it's looking the
same
similar to me yeah so this is just you
can i guess show this one file this one
picture zach um c-line but you know i
don't i have no idea if this is
legitimate this is just flicker um this
is claimed to be a sea lion flipper and
you can see the claws exactly as you say
sort of you know back offset by a couple
inches
beyond the terminal edges of the flipper
yeah
shouldn't be flicker it should be
flipper
but
last time i was on flickr and it's been
a while they had more than just um
pinniped flippers on it mm-hmm yeah so
that may be the reason for it being
called pickers
all right the biology jokes are going to
come to a halt here because we're going
to drive off what remains of our
audience if we don't cut that out
okay um wow where is my
wh what happened to the questions what
happened they've all been answered
darling no they just okay um
yes or anything else where might
fingernails be headed they might be
disappearing i wonder
um i mean certainly like what's what's
the
toenail on the baby toe doing
uh
just threatening to get ingrown at any
moment it's it seems i mean they all
kind of seem useless i mean i guess with
your hands you can see like it might be
protective when you're doing certain
things um but with regard to the toes it
seems not that useful i mean if you drop
something on your toe it hurts
regardless i don't think the nail really
helps that much and maybe i'm wrong
maybe i would miss them if they were go
on the toenails but yeah i don't know i
don't know it is a bit mysterious yeah
is the fundamental assumption underlying
game theory
when instantly did it transition from
being game hypothesis to game theory
that that's in the question all right
that i can answer
that the context of the games of game
theory is zero sum positive sum or
negative sum
uh as far as you're concerned in biology
and the evolution of life
as far as you're concerned is biology
and the evolution of life a positive sum
game
what about physics
that's like that's three
questions physics can take a long walk
on a short pier
okay that was the fourth question oh
well i just thought i'd start at the end
sure no absolutely okay um what did it
transition from being game hypothesis to
game theory you really have an answer to
this i do kind of
but no i think i think it's important
because you know i am of course
constantly running a program that checks
whether or not people are using these
things including me i screw it up every
now and again but it checks to see
whether you're using it correctly and
the point is it's not wrong to say you
know we're looking for a theory of
everything we are looking for a theory
of everything right the point is theory
is what you get when it works hypothesis
is what you have before you know whether
it has worked right and
and you know string theory ain't nothing
it doesn't predict a damn thing so the
point is it's not a theory or a
hypothesis it's
it's a notion or an intuition or
something
you know or it's math but it's not a
scientific theory
so anyway my point is why
is the realm called game theory because
it wouldn't make any sense to call it
game hypothesis the point is it is a
search for
the theory of games
oh it's like evolutionary theory right
okay so this is actually it's not
game theory isn't just one isn't just
one hypothesis right and um
i'm a th it's a lens game theory is a
lens it's a lens i'm a theorist
what i come up with are hypotheses and
if i do it well they become theories
yeah right
um but you know i'm a theorist because
the whole point of the exercise even if
i don't control that last step is um is
the generation of theory yeah so the
answer
you didn't answer when did it transition
from game hypothesis to game theory you
said actually no this
the umbrella term should be game theory
just as the umbrella term should be
evolutionary theorists not evolutionary
hypothesis hypothesis correct correct
okay um
is the fundamental assumption underlying
game theory that the context of the
games of game theory is zero sum
positive some are negative sum
yeah is that a complete solution set
well except the person
is actually and then when they say what
about physics they kind of deliver
the
uh the punch line
which is yeah everything is zero some
negative sum or positive sum until you
get to the ultimate at which point it's
zero sum
right
um and
so anyway yeah i think that is the the
underlying assumption
um i mean i think that's a complete
solution set
yeah especially if especially if you
include that last dimension in which
you're you know at any given level you
may have positive zero or negative sum
but there's a recognition that you know
there's a limited amount of stuff in the
universe and uh you know once you turn
it all into paper clips it's mission
accomplished
awesome
so the final question in this multi-part
question then is as far as you're
concerned is biology and the evolution
of life a positive sum game
um
yes
it is in the following sense
we often play a zero-sum game because we
don't know how to get to the next
frontier what frontiers do is they
introduce positive sum
and the point is it is always limited
right it cannot help but be limited
which is every frontier is finite right
they are all inherently fine
jesus um
that was shocking
but this is why
the last chapter of our book
argues that the fourth frontier which we
effectively say is a perpetual thing
is an architected steady state
right the point is you there is no
infinite frontier but you could make
something that felt like one right just
the same way it always feels like spring
inside your house
you can architect a steady state that
feels like growth and is therefore it's
like you know is a treadmill an
infinitely long sidewalk
no but it might as well be right
yeah
man we got we got cat madness here today
yup they want to go outside
as do i yeah
all right
uh i also zach i forgot to check out
when we started just so i can keep an
eye on the time
so was it like uh it was like 2 54 or
something
okay
loved brett's conversation with jonathan
pagio
maybe you can talk with john vervacky or
vicky
seems like your perspectives would
bridge in a significant way
yeah so we had the three of us talked a
while back now and it's great and i
think i think i think that may be in the
works well we were actually on the
calendar and i can't remember what got
in the way yeah but it's not for lack of
interest
yes we all agree that that would be a
good conversation and uh that there is
an awful lot of overlap in thinking and
i think i have the sense that
uh john vervecki is
a separate evolution of many
similar ideas that cover
uh similar phenomena yeah so anyway
that's that's always useful yeah
useful and interesting and a little bit
fraught because
as i always point out
anytime you generate your own framework
for thinking about something you
inevitably redefine terms because the
terms that you're handed aren't
aren't uh sufficiently refined to do the
heavy lifting right so some of the
conversation has to be about just
establishing the dictionary right which
is not easy because you know
we all forget what terms we use in some
special way
and
uh so
anyway my my sense is that unfortunately
and i think this is a little bit what
happened
with jonathan pajot as well
is there's no fast forwarding that
process it's not like you can say let's
spend the first 15 minutes defining our
glossaries and then we'll get to the
substance yeah it's a couple of weeks of
learning how somebody thinks before you
realize ah this is where i need to stand
in order that they don't keep tripping
me and the categories won't be the
boundaries around the for god's sake
fairfax is demonstrating his deep
disrespect for the primary literature
he's chewing on a
peer-reviewed paper that you've got
printed out here and having pulled that
away from him he's decided to move on to
some velcro
i don't i don't disagree with his
conclusion it's just very distracting
it's very very distracting
yeah well he's he's the next producer
um
there will also be so it's it's oh it is
exactly as you say very interesting to
discover oh
you've arrived at some place very
similar through a totally different uh
totally different domain totally
different discipline and you know maybe
autodidact maybe an established
discipline that didn't even we didn't
even know we're doing the same thing
not only it's it would be one thing if
it's like oh you call it x i call it y
cool perfect match uh but it's rarely
going to be a perfect match uh and
uh you know put aside like the
territoriality over like you know what
my words better because i've been using
it for longer um more to the point there
will be
nuance uh
nuanced differences between the two
versions
and uh to some degree you know there
will be a venn diagram and you know the
more overlap the more likely you can be
like okay when you say x i mean y but
very often
simply because of the different approach
that
the two fields the two people took
the terms may be a very close match but
not a perfect match and figuring out
exactly the nature of the mismatch is
part of the process yep as well i always
go into it uh
with the agreement
that i don't care whether the terms we
walk out with are my terms or your terms
it'll be a mixture but we need a term
for everything that needs a term and we
need to have agreement on what terms
mean which thing you can't keep
speaking your own language if you're
gonna
overlap with somebody you have to figure
out what language is your you know your
lingua franca and it needs a term for
everything and the terms need to be
sufficiently precise that you can say
things and know exactly what is meant by
them um yep but you know
it's a lot of work but it's also very
rewarding work when you find somebody
you can talk to who you know is
interested enough in the same things to
have terms indeed for them
indeed
should we be concerned about cumulative
radiation exposure from yearly
mammograms dental x-rays etc
yeah
oh yes and no yeah i mean it's not the
biggest thing that we should be
concerned about well but that's pretty
low bar so let's talk about um
it's gonna be mimesis right
um
there are two
separate things that in most people's
minds are not
distinct which we have to separate
one of them
are
radioactive particles
and the other is radiation
and radioactive particles emit radiation
we need to be really really concerned
about radioactive particles and we don't
need to be that concerned about
radiation
there are levels of radiation that are
sufficient to be concerning by and large
because of the awareness of the danger
of radiation things like dental x-rays
have been reduced in their intensity a
great deal basically we've gotten really
efficient we can use a small number of
x-rays to get a high resolution image
these things get worse when we do fancy
newfangled stuff like you know that
rotating x-ray that goes around your
whole head and takes really many many
many x-rays and then compiles them into
a three-dimensional model that's
obviously a lot of x-rays compared to a
static
shot and you need to be more you know
concerned about something like you're
talking about that thing in the airport
or
uh also an mri yeah yeah i don't go
through the thing in the airport that's
for sure yeah it's not to say that i you
know i did once i was late enough for a
plane that i did go through it it's not
like i think it's likely to be fatal to
you in a small number of interactions
but i was traveling enough and i just
don't think it's worth it you can be at
the airport long enough that the pat
done doesn't keep you from getting on
your plane yeah
but anyway the point is
i i worry
much more than most about radioactive
particles it's really bad to ingest
those things it's really bad whether you
breathe them in or eaten them it doesn't
matter it's really dangerous
um and they you know we know actually a
fair amount of what happens with
radioactive isotopes like
cesium and strontium uh
cesium which i believe goes to muscle
strontium which goes to bone these are
really big dangers with respect to
cancers but radiation
we are built we
we did not
evolve with lots of
radioactive cesium or strontium
much less
uranium and plutonium the reason being
these things aren't stable and so to the
extent that they were created at some
point in the past they've disappeared
we now recreate them
and ingesting them is bad because you
don't have a good system for dealing
with them on the other hand radiation
that just simply threatens your dna
threatens to disrupt it in ways that
when it is repaired may not spell the
same thing and therefore could in theory
be
cancerous we've got lots of protections
from that happening right and so you
know telomeres is one good example
it's a fail-safe where if you get a
mutation that starts a tumor it doesn't
end up being a tumor ends up being a
prototumor and you never know you have
it or you do know you have a mole and
you don't know
that it's anything beyond that so anyway
worry less about radiation and more
about radioactive particles that's my
advice
good
nice
uh
next question i wish i had in the can a
good answer to this
but i have a place to go where you might
quickly be able to find if not this lots
of other good things that are kind of
related
you indicated that avocado oil is
healthier than that of seed oils can you
please elaborate on this
there is at this point a ton of research
that suggests that
the increase in seed oil consumption
in basically post industrial
revolution america is
one of the things that can be most
easily pointed to as contributing to
many of our very bad health outcomes
i do not have the
answer in the can about you know what
what all we think is happening there
and
what i will point to instead since i'm
just not going to
i'm not going to try to riff here
because i don't remember at the moment
is i will point to this
extraordinary sub stack uh
slow down farmstead you can put on my
screen if you like
uh slow down farmstead written by my
friend tara uh who
um i assume she's written about seed
oils and their their health effects at
some point here um but she's written
about um you know nutrient density
density dense foods and fasting
and various ways to be nourished
and just so you know how food on the go
that allows the people whom she loves to
stay you know deeply and deliciously
nourished rather than having to grab
something out of
anything fast and so i'm sure somewhere
in here there's this analysis and
i know many people have talked about it
but i'm going to
do you the service of pointing you to
slow down farmstead
can i ask you a basic question yeah you
probably do know the answer to okay i
hope so
i i have known a lot of these things and
i've just at the moment i've been
thinking about sunlight instead yes
avocado oil yeah
is it from the avocado meat or is it the
avocado seed yeah so and i think the
very first time
this came up on darkhorse um
i hadn't thought about avocado oil
actually explicitly i thought about seed
oils and such but i sort of thought
avocado oil might be from the seed and
someone i remember who i apologize
corrected me and said no avocado oil is
not a seed oil it's not coming from the
seed interesting yeah so canola
safflower sunflower grape seed also
known as rapeseed
all of those are seed oils
okay what about
palm oil that's going to be a seed oil
at the at the biological morphological
level
how is it from the point of view of
health i i think not good but i don't
yeah um
and we have
olive oil and
avocado oil coconut oil
uh right which is a seed but it's but a
coconut coconut is such a different kind
of beast
yeah it'd be interesting to know why
coconut oil is different but i agree
that's my instinct but but with it with
respect at least to
this is this is not proof of anything
but uh it being solid at room
temperature
um is pointing to it's being a little
bit more like animal fat
yeah right now and again boy like
there's so many people
amazing people who really know this
stuff and i i think in this regard we
really do have a fairly depth deep
understanding like we being the bigger
science community and
we don't necessarily we know what we
avoid and we know what we what we cook
with and what we don't but but it's
interesting that olive and avocado are
exceptional fruits in the sense that the
reward is not sugar it's fat yes
yes quite so
the reward for the for the distributor
of the seed yeah um so anyway i wonder
if that's not and maybe i mean actually
maybe with coconut uh it's gonna be
something similar where um you know
coconut i guess oh wait a second
because the seat is the
i got it yeah
the seed is the um
the seed is the fruit and the
distributor of coconuts is oceans yeah
and the point is the thing that makes
the
basically
you know if you've got a bird and both
avocado and olive are going to be bird
distributed fruits
yeah the the origin original avocados
being so much smaller than these
once you get in the markets now now like
you know like orange sized avocados is
probably not at any anything like what
yeah
wild avocados are we know from south
america
um that the forest avocados which are
eaten by the spectacled bears are little
things yes exactly so the spectacle
bears come down out of the perimo for
the summers when the avocados are
fruiting and we've never seen them but
this is this is what we've been told by
people who apparently know these things
now i am not going to argue that those
bears are birds but i am going to argue
that avocados elsewhere are distributed
by birds which i'm almost sure of but um
anyway i i could see um arboreal mammals
going after avocados oh i could see a
lot of things yeah then the question is
what is the
plant what is the what is the plant
hoping for yeah um but anyway if you
imagine birds are long-distance
distributors they're very good ones
actually yeah um
and oceans are too and coconut the the
weird thing here is that coconuts
basically
grow
near the ocean and they
have these basically boats attached to
them these big
woody um fibrous things and they float
tens hundreds sometimes thousands of
miles they're on the canoe
and then of course you will often find
them sprouting on the beach somewhere
else who knows where they fell in the
water but i have this picture um that i
took on nosy mangaby this little tiny
island off the coast of madagascar which
was intact forest
uh and you know there's a coconut
growing and it's like it clearly rolled
up on the beach and then there was low
tide for long enough that it it started
to grow and like oh this is the only
coconut tree on the entire island and
here it is
all right well i'm going to i'm going to
uh gamble on a hypothesis here
um the thing about
fats the reason that animals store
energy
in fat is that animals move and fat is
light and therefore cheap to transport
right plants don't tend to store
energy in
fat
because they don't have to move it
around in their seeds they do store it
as fat which is why we can get it from
grape seeds or whatever because the
point is again at the point you've got a
seed that you want crepe grape seed is
not grapes it's not grapes no it's i
mean it's also called rapeseed i don't
know if g got added because it reminded
people i don't know the history
nonetheless there's a lot of fat in
seeds because there's a premium on
getting a lot of energy in that package
because that package is again on the
move right so the sessile plant may not
have a lot of fat in it the seed will
tend to have fat in it
and for a
disperser
who is going to travel a long distance
there is again a priority on high
density high energy density which fat is
good yeah um high energy energy density
per unit of weight because basically
it's cheaper for an animal who's eaten
it to fly having eaten it
um so the question is is the thing
that's keeping the um
the
avocado uh or keeping the um coconut
afloat
and providing it a whole bunch of energy
with a combination of the fat in the air
right um
and
so anyway avocado olive and coconut may
all have reasons to have made fats that
are not
um well you would sort of expect
i'm going to talk myself in circles here
but um
but there might be something about the
long-distance dispersal and the nature
of the fats utilized
[Music]
which unites these three things anyway
please in your hate mail
point us to any relevant literature yes
logic that would be necessary to unpack
the puzzle yeah now i'd like to um
my guess is tara may have written about
it in which case i really will recommend
whatever she's written about it but um
i'll bet there's a good
simple explanation for at least some of
what we've just been talking about out
there
uh
what
what would it look like if an enemy
wanted america to defeat itself from
within
yes uh somebody should put together a
sci-fi documentary in which they
describe the present in excruciating
detail and that would be how the enemy
defeats us from within
yeah having
gotten a substantial portion of the
population to deny the most obvious and
simple
biological realities necessary to
reproduce and to to fight to fight those
things tooth and nail and to even i've
even seen in the wake of the alito leak
earlier this week some
some news organizations doubling down on
talking about pregnant people yeah like
um
not
not going to remain intact as a society
that way are we no
no um no we're not no you could do a lot
of things you could feminize the
military that would be cool that would
work you could also
[Music]
you could cause everybody who wasn't of
the dominant phenotype to suspect
everybody who was of the dominant
phenotype of some uncurable
moral defect that would make them
unpartnerable
you could you could provoke anger
against the people who are doing the
hard work of trying to maintain law and
order and maintain that they are all
bastards
oh yeah you could you could cause the
law and order people to resent enforcing
the law yeah that's good you could
attack the concept of merit
sure sure claim that that was actually
a trick of the dominant
phenotype
and you could inform very small children
that they're not what they think they
are and if they are they're wrong and if
they're not well then we'll help them
transform themselves into what they
think they are oh yeah you could inform
them of that at school and then you
could uh tell them to be very very quiet
and not tell their parents don't tell
their parents yeah you could do that you
could that would help undermine any
sense of family and sort of uh
sort of social integrity
right
yeah family again a a trick it's hard to
imagine how any of this would work but
like you could do any of these theory
yeah we're plausibility not a limit sure
all these things yeah you could uh print
a [ __ ] ton of money
and uh
right
yeah because that
that would make some sense um you could
i just actually disappear the words and
uh and and language of anyone who didn't
go along with what you were saying
oh yeah you could you could convince
them of special you could accuse them of
being the con artist some of this is not
about uh
an enemy wind american to itself from
within although you know frankly i would
say that any enemy anyone who is
acting in any of these ways whether or
not they think they're acting
patriotically or not they're not they're
not they are the enemy they are the
enemy oh you could um
[Music]
you could up end
the established de taunt over the most
divisive issues the country has ever
navigated after printing the [ __ ] ton of
money
sure
yeah that would that would also that
would also be effective that would be
useful right right
um you could dehumanize anyone uh with
whom your team finds any reason to
disagree and sort of um you know
separate them out into their constituent
parts and then make fun of those parts
and then argue that if you do that ever
you are yourself the enemy and the
problem
yeah that's good um
you could
uh yeah you could come up with something
onerous and needlessly dangerous
you could mandate it for everybody in
every industry and then you take whoever
is like wait no i don't want that thing
and you fire them all
but i mean you could even
you could even have produced the thing
for which that onerous and dangerous
treatment was produced in the first
place
on the basis by claiming that you're
doing it only in order to preserve the
health of the people
then you've now produced the thing
that's actually
making the problems
yeah well okay here's some ideas were
you to want to destroy a society from
within you could take any one of these
and then just i mean you wouldn't want
to do them all at once because it would
be too much
you couldn't get the entire population
to go along with it could you go along
with it no you're going to attack merit
come on you're going to demonize the
majority population and claim that they
have a
moral disorder that
makes them unpartnerable i mean nobody's
going to buy this [ __ ] yeah you're going
to claim like turtles or slide rules and
men or women that's not it's not how it
is
okay
where were we
[Laughter]
we were tearing ourselves apart from
within yeah i guess okay well there's oh
okay we only have a few more minutes
happy mother's day dr hein much love to
you and yours thank you that's tomorrow
correct um
as a gay man i'm still dying to hear
brett's gay hypothesis when will we hear
it bye
it's not bad it's gay okay um
i'm just going to keep going because i
know you're not going to reveal it right
now no soon i hope soon you you you get
the society wrangled so that we can
actually put something on the calendar
rent the hall and not uh be told oh i'm
sorry you have to
refund everybody's ticket money because
it's the new diseased viewer and the
mandates are x y and z and we'll do it
regarding masks outdoors some people are
just uninformed but in winter i find it
keeps my face warm like a scarf and in
spring i could see it helping with
pollen allergies thoughts
this is interesting there was there was
a day
i think i think i only remember this one
day but last winter
when i when i went out and of course i
had a mask with me because you had to
but i had a scarf because i i do love
scarves and a hat and it was dry when i
went out but cold and it just started
blowing blowing and raining
and
i did put on the
the mask because it did actually keep my
face warm and
i'd never love it i don't like breathing
in air that i've just breathed out i
don't i don't like how it feels but um
i don't know if if it would block pollen
sufficiently i mean i guess an n95 would
probably 95 certainly would i i think
even uh even just a classified school
will catch i mean maybe not certainly
not all of it but yeah a significant
amount of pollen
um i do i can't remember what the
scenario was but there was a point two
months ago maybe maybe it was less than
that maybe it was pollen but there was
some case where i actually
did have some problem i had a mask with
me and didn't think to put it on because
i've now become
so resentful of this stuff no but i mean
the like the big leaf maples really went
to town this year with the pollen yeah
and uh
and yeah it might well help
sure which you know unfortunately it's
all so damn politicized now it's it's
hard
to remember that yeah right exactly as
you say
okay um
every western country from canada to the
eu has drafted laws to keep twitter
censored
do you think they'll kill him if that
doesn't work
um
for reasons that we have discussed
the
difference between a world in which
twitter successfully escapes the
censorious impulse
and twitter fails to escape
there's all the difference in the world
i don't think we know what happens if it
succeeds we know what happens if it
fails because we're living it already
but i
who knows what lengths
they might go to to prevent this because
the point is it isn't just twitter once
you have twitter as a free place it will
cause a race to the top and if we can
help
it's inevitable and the same thing is
true for universities and the same thing
is true for newspapers and so we should
just
keep your eye on anything where somebody
threatens to put one
of whatever it is together that invades
the problem
and expect fireworks
okay uh two more questions
there are a few more than that but we're
going to get to two more here
uh an account called storm for congress
on twitter
claims that i think this is how i'm
going to read this question here i i
think that's what the framing of this
question means
that
the dod is retesting and reviewing all
service members for hiv and sickle cell
could this be connected to the vaccine
mandates
uh also i would like your thoughts on
the dod covering up dmed data i don't
know any i don't know what dmed is yeah
okay yeah
um basically
because the military is the military
it keeps better data
than what's dmed i just don't know what
that stands i remember what it stands
for okay but i think what this is
referring to is there's basically a
database
that's like you know the equivalent of
vares but for military
personnel
and
so the point is hey they vaccinated a
whole heck of a large fraction of the
military and
they have pretty good evidence on what
happened because you know if you weren't
discharged you're still being tracked by
that system
so i don't
you know i don't know how they get out
of that but on the other hand the
military is downstream of the same
capture corruption force that has gotten
everything else so
i'm not expecting that data to emerge
and suddenly us all to become
clear-headed about what's going on i'm
expecting something
gets in the road
uh what about the first part of the
question um
according to an account on twitter the
dod is retesting or reviewing all
service members for hiv and sickle cell
could this be connected to the vaccine
mandates
um there's there i don't know what sick
i haven't heard a sickle cell connection
well
but it cannot be sickle cell i mean
sickle cell is entirely genetically
heritable
right it's not it's not vectored it's
not contagious this is why i'm wondering
about the phraseology of the question
yeah
you've got hiv
which obviously can't come
from covid or a vaccine
well yeah there's
but
you could have immunodeficiency which we
know does
okay in other words immunodeficiency is
a syndrome it's not a pathogen
and it
can be driven by a lot of things that
disrupt a cascade likewise sickle cell
the symptomology of sickle cell anemia
yeah you could have
you have or you don't you are you're not
heterogeneous for sickle cell or
heterogeneous yes or cyclists for sickle
cell um but maybe it's controlled and
then now it's not
right or yeah or you could imagine a
disruption of hemoglobin formation that
would cause a sickle cell-like
phenomenon in people who genetically
weren't
heterozygous
i ain't saying that happened but i would
at least want to know if we're really
talking about them testing for sickle
cell the genetic condition are they
checking genes
and presumably anyone in the military
has already known whether or not they're
i mean because because it doesn't
manifest like you're not
not if you're heterozygous at all
well that's the thing is you have
heterozygote advantage so it doesn't
manifest in a way that would necessarily
show up well i mean you got as
far as i remember and this is such like
it's such a simplistic example that it's
used everywhere uh where you learn first
genetics and i i've always wondered if
it's not more complicated than that but
the
heterozygote advantage for sickle cell
is supposed to be about resistance to
malaria but i thought that there was
also
maybe only sometimes maybe not ever
maybe i'm just wrong about this
some low level of sickling um in your
cells if you're heterozygous for sickle
cell yeah the way uh the way we
teach it whether or not it's accurate
yeah you know it makes sense with the
cartoon in the damn textbook whether the
cartoon in the damn textbook is
informative or not
but um
the idea is it is the reduced capacity
of a heterozygote to carry oxygen that
makes the blood inhospitable to malaria
that's right so the blood does look
different so the blood cells are are
slightly cycled there's
something right or half of them are or
something like that
yeah
okay
final question
if the november elections led to a
republican congressional super majority
that is veto proof coming in january
2023
what do you think the wogie karki
ogegarki
no wokigaki that's better woken
i transpose sorry i
you you did it exactly right here uh
transposed the constants i'm going to
start over if the november elections led
to a republican congressional
supermajority that is veto proof like 61
or more right 60 is not veto proof but
61 would be veto proof
uh coming in january 2023 what do you
think the wokey would do
love you guys
well
this
i hate to say it i don't want to be that
guy but um a
the fact that this is a question might
mean that it's not a question because
the point is
uh the powers that be
do stuff i mean remember how we got joe
biden
nobody was to vote for joe biden how do
we get joe biden well facebook helped
yeah i mean something helped well we
know facebook helped and presumably is
are we certain that we know all of the
things that helped no we don't we don't
know all the things but i'm just saying
look we got a basic thing that we know
right we know the democratic party
doesn't like primaries that actually
function like primaries because you
could get a really dangerous person like
andrew yang or kelsey gabbard
imagine president gabbard terrible
terrifying doesn't speak for those dems
no sir that's terrifying because she is
one of those what do you call them
freethinkers patriot that's it right now
imagine that you had a patriot in the
office of the presidency i mean it's
almost unthinkable i can't remember a
time right it's uh it's i think obama
was i thought he was um well i don't
know what happened with obama he
certainly sounded like one yeah you know
the man could already but
um but anyway
the point is look something in the
democratic party riggs primaries what
did he say he said something in the
democratic party riggs primaries yeah
you know what
when when uh bernie sanders um went to
court over this the democratic party did
not argue that they hadn't rigged the
primary they argued it was their primary
they were entitled to reagan so i didn't
make this up
i mean you know well that was just the
legal defense of course they could have
argued that they hadn't done it sure
come on brett well give them a break
why are you so mean to them why am i
always so mean to the democratic party
and the democratic national committee i
don't know probably something wrong with
me i would guess but yes i think so i
mean that's what they think right what
have they ever been wrong
when have they ever been wrong right
yeah i don't know but anyway my point is
a thing
with as much power as this thing has
you know we never talked about no i
don't i think we should come back to it
the correspondence dinner
this year this year
it was quite something and it really it
was eye-opening i
i only have a slight glimmer that
something i don't know i don't really
know what happened well the president
gave a speech president showed up
president showed up he gave a speech
hold of them to let him show up it was
risky he did all right though i mean it
was not it wasn't a good performance but
in light of what could have happened
right it was pretty impressive okay um
but
it's all the stuff around it that was
like
jaw-dropping and unbelievable anyway we
should come back to it another time but
suffice it to say
there's an awful lot of power that power
is not interested in playing fair
elections are about playing fair i don't
know and what i don't know
about general elections but i do know
about primaries they're they're rigged
they're openly rigged
joe biden swooped in because
somebody needed something to regain
control of a field in which you know you
did have these very very dangerous
people like uh andrew yang and tulsi
gabbard uh
surprisingly well and foaming at the
mouth patriots oh man at the mouth
patriots so anyway no i don't trust that
this could happen on the other hand you
know the thing and i keep saying this
the thing that we do actually owe donald
trump for is that he proved that it was
possible to beat the establishment he
succeeded in doing it and it's
unfortunate yeah the problems didn't
want him they did not want it i don't
want him and you know it is unfortunate
that the character traits but
unfortunately it may have proven that
the republicans are less good at
controlling their own party than the
democrats are i think that's true
um but anyway my point would be look in
order to do what trump did you needed to
have
character defects that meant that when
he got there he wasn't able to do what
needed to be done
if you had had if you had handed andrew
donald trump
it would have been a very different
thing and it didn't get to be a
different thing because unfortunately
the guy who was capable of beating the
republicans wasn't
capable of recognizing
the opportunity
and also of course
the powers that be
wanted to make sure that he couldn't
wield that power and yeah we couldn't
see the the good that he did and he
wouldn't be allowed to do
any more good than they could keep him
from doing and
we weren't going to get an honest record
of what he did and didn't accomplish and
he wasn't going to
recognize what to do with the cards
necessarily but
anyway now we've gotten ourselves in
enough trouble
to sign off yeah absolutely
um
you know praising obama and trump in the
same little griff that's
deadly
i don't think i've praised either
oh i said it was a good order you know
obama yeah in both cases anyway
it was me more than you who did any
praising i mean it wasn't high praise
low praise praise
okay uh
we i think are done
we're done
we are finished
signing off this was dark horse
we'll see you somewhere at some point
no that's not it that is not it at all
we will be back but it's going to be a
little while but do stay tuned for uh
one or more guest episodes that brett
will have uh be hosting with guests in
the meantime but we will be back the two
of us for our next live stream
on thursday may 26th immediately
followed by one on saturday may 28th so
uh so hang on to your hats at that point
but until then enjoy most of may i hope
it's gorgeous for you and um
i don't know relatively harmless like
earth was sometimes
referred to as in the douglas adams
trilogy oh i said relatively yeah not
relatively yeah um
that in the first edition of the
hitchhiker's guide i understand it was
harmless and then after ford prefect
came and assessed he got the adjective
added mostly
mostly harmless
uh well may we uh maybe we do better
than that
maybe better than that
uh we will see you next time in the
meantime
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside and we're a life
preserver
[Music]
you